solve for P so we have negative 3 P
minus 7 is less than P plus 9 so let's
isolate the peas on one side of this
equation we could do it on the left-hand
side so to do that we want to get rid of
this P right over here so let's subtract
p from both sides so I am subtracting p
from both sides of this of this
inequality the left-hand side negative 3
p minus p well that's going to be
negative 4 p minus 7 is less center
equal to or no sorry just less than not
less than or equal to is just less than
p minus p is 0 so we just have a 9 over
here and then we can add if we want to
isolate the peas we can add 7 to both
sides to get rid of this negative 7 over
here so let's add 7 to both sides of
this equation sorry this inequality it's
not an equation it's an inequality and
we have negative 4 p nate- 7 plus 7
those cancel out is less than 9 plus 7
which is 16 now if we want to isolate
the P if we want to get rid of this
negative 4 coefficient we want to
multiply both sides of the inequality by
its inverse by negative one-fourth or
another way we could think about we
could divide both sides of this
inequality by negative 4 but we have to
remember if you multiply or divide both
sides of an inequality by a negative
number you have to swap the inequality
so if we could let me do it this way-
for P over negative 4 and we have 16 /
negative 4 so I just divided both sides
by negative 4 but since i'm dividing by
a negative number or if i had multiplied
by a negative this is equivalent to
multiplying by negative one-fourth i
have to swap i have to swap the
inequality it goes from less than to
being greater than and now this negative
4 cancels to negative 4 we have P is
greater than 16 divided by negative 4 is
is negative 4 and we could have done it
another way we could have grouped all of
the peas on the right hand side of the
equation let me do that just to show you
there's multiple ways to do this so you
have negative 3 P minus 7 is less than P
plus 9 let's go
the peas on the right hand side so we
could add 3 P to both sides so let's add
3 P to both sides so we get just a
negative 7 is less than P plus 3 P is
for P plus 9 now we can subtract 9 from
both sides to get rid of that nine over
there and so we will get negative 7-9 is
negative 16 is less than 4p and now we
can divide both sides by a positive 4 so
we just have a pee on the right-hand
side we divide both sides by a positive
number you don't swap the inequality so
we just want to divide both sides by a
positive 4 and so the left-hand side
becomes negative 4 is less than 4 p over
p 4 p over 4 is just P so we get p is
greater than negative 4 or negative 4 is
less than P which is the exact same
thing we have over here p is greater
than negative 4 or negative 4 is less
than P and so let's graph it here let's
graph our solution so it would look like
this maybe we have negative 5 negative 4
negative 3 negative 2 negative 1 0 1 and
so p is greater than negative 4 p is
greater than negative 4 so we're not
going to equal it we're not going to
include negative 4 because we don't it's
not a greater than or equal so we have
to put a open circle around negative 4
but then we're going to include all of
the values greater than that so we're
going to go to the right we're going to
go to the right and then let's just
verify that this makes reasonable amount
of sense let's find something that
should work so negative 3 is included
let's verify that negative 3 works so if
we have negative 3 times negative 3 so
that's the negative 3 and 4 p.m. putting
in negative 3 minus 7 it should be less
than negative 3 plus 9 so this is 9-7
which is 2 is less than negative 3 plus
9 is 6
this is true so negative three
definitely worked negative five should
not work let's verify that negative
three times negative 5 minus seven let's
see how that relates well let's see if
this is true whether it's less than
negative five plus nine so this is
positive 15-7 is 88 is less than
negative five plus nine is for this is
not true it is not less than four so
negative five does not work so at least
from to one point that's outside of the
solution said it definitely did not work
in one point that was in the solutions
that it did work so we're feeling pretty
good about our solution